ciao a tutti allora avete presente la
paura per alcune persone questa qui può
essere immediatamente innescata non lo
so dai ragni dagli spazi angusti dalle
altezze al buio bene nel mio caso
d'amore viene facilmente indotta dalle
cinque cose che sto per elencare vi era
una delle nostre mete realizzate molto
ridicolo barriere sono le cose con gli
occhi però non le cose con gli occhi di
voi mangiai umani se mi fanno paura però
non così tanto quanto le cose con gli
occhi
[Musica]
un'altra paura che o diciamo che più un
ansia costante così a psicopatico e che
mi rubino che io mi perdo le cose perché
almeno una volta al giorno mi lamento
con mia madre per qualcosa che ho perso
il nome silvio fiera ma se rifinire
fatevi un litigio ma rischiosa numero ma
il cuscino o male sull'orologio mai lo
sgambetto
ma il suo claudia non per questo che col
passare del tempo finito per proteggere
qualsiasi cosa mi circonda il cellulare
alla navigazione andrà i miei pari alla
somma cultura rami così tragica
mentre ai miei traguardi a nemi
intelligenza ma la mia castigata
l'attivista all'arte alla tenera maniera
alcuni alla penna di elena ciao elisa
[Musica]
20 agosto alterate fiore di tanto
scarsa
per fiore di campo 18 fiori campo 18z è
fiorita perciò tutti i tasti discute
scarico a [ __ ] colpisca di merda col
cazzo che le faccia ormai di
informazione brutti stronzi
kaspersky ne sono sicuro tutti mi fai
matri mattina è perfetto anche libro che
sto scrivendo e il con l'acquisto a quel
pagamento che ho fatto relativo acquisto
di bambola gonfiabile kulula è stato
protetto e sentirle le foto affermativo
foto di orgia essere tutte progetto
eppure protetto il bivio negativo al
caricato tuo video sul forum pochi ma se
in alimenti casa tv un'ultima cosa è
perfetto anti willy affermativo protetto
cane che score giocate piscio come il
piccolo alla co come se i the man who
will
[Musica]
poi ho paura ma è proprio il disagio
perché poi non ci riesco di far
trasparire emozioni sconvenienti oddio è
arrivato il momento della barzelletta
con questo scemo ma che cazzo dei
capelli che si è fatto comunque gli
occhiali notte dai ridi ridi provarli
dei tre golfi lanci di ridere di più
red kat arriva la single
ma dice van gaal in chiesa e cazzo mi
sentii il ghetto battuta del merda
voglio morire io non so se tu vai io che
ne so
fingiamo di luca strano ma la piena
ricordo i nomi dei miei fratelli
l'atto di nascita veniva dennis non vado
a fare l'analisi tra queste mani per dai
cieli della donna così mani
che cosa te ne pare
una merda suggestivo
[Musica]
sì che no grazie che cos'è un regalo di
nuovo arrivato il compleanno un pensiero
[Musica]
che chicchi che cosa sono le mie utili
piedi o il santo mazzetta pubblicato il
comune dei piedi che del mio coli plan
di miglionico
ma perché tanta grazia e la chimera lo
so alle rotaie in treno smetti che pur
sempre cia russa che avventurismi che
pone fine alla tua vita un'altra cosa
che mi terrorizza
ma proprio tanto tanto sono le ati vista
e come se non bastasse poi mi fa schifo
anche il miele
quindi avrebbe potuto inutile almeno si
fa il kinder fetta al latte allora sono
utili e infine un'altra cosa che mi fa
paura ma sono le leggende metropolitane
oppure che guardarmi pronte mirenda
sterile può ora guardare in alto quando
guarda in basso nello specchio proporre
che dal vate resi con i serpenti
oppure che da sotto al letto mio felino
delle mani o paure dei men in generale
specialmente questo poveri dietro ogni
angolo ci siano degli assassini proprio
uccidermi può ora guardare la notte
nello specchietto retrovisore o la ferma
convinzione che ogni persona che contro
notte sola sia un fantasmi zombie e fino
il terrore che dentro gli uffici si
ricava il potere fini questo video
chiedendovi non so di scrivermi magari
quali sono le vostre 5 paure o di
mandarmi dei video e risposta che posso
vedere magari troppo paura di leggerli
basta monte non qualcosa disconnesso o
un gatto
a
[Musica]